outside
too shot right
well
the house will come to
order the chair recognizes a member from
Auburn representative Osburn who moves
at the house adjourn from the session of
February 1 2024 are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay eyes have it and the
house is adjourned the house will attend
to a Prayer by house chaplain Reverend
Bob Stewart pastor of St Paul's United
Manchester good morning New Hampshire
House of Representatives morning good
morning Mr
Speaker let us prepare our hearts for
prayer good morning God it is with
gratitude that we thank you for this day
today and every day we always seek your
guidance and
direction in Genesis 1 and two we read
about the creation story and when you
had created the world we live in
today you rested and said all is
good oh God today we see the Brokenness
of that which you have
created but with your One Pair of Hands
we know it can be mended and healed as
we put our trust in you and we are
willing to do our
part God today perhaps there may be
legislation that is presented to help in
the areas we see the Brokenness within
this great state of New
Hampshire let us read listen and discern
each people piece of
legislation with the wisdom that you
have given each of us through us may we
help in mending some of the Brokenness
we experience
today oh god of love I again ask for a
special blessing upon all the New
Hampshire state representatives and the
leaders that are present
today place your guiding hand on each of
them as they navigate through the
business before them
today bless each one oh God and help
them to feel your presence amongst us
today and oh God may I ask for a special
healing prayer for our young friend
Henry Smith at home today with the
flu Oh Spirit of the Living God fall AR
fresh on us melt us mold us fill us and
use us oh Spirit of the Living God fall
all aresh on us today to you oh God be
am the chair recognizes a member from
marac from senator mchu who will lead us
Allegiance toag the United States of
America to for it stands one nation God
all the chair now recognizes Khloe Hardy
a senior at miramac high school who will
anthem can you
see by the dawn's
early light what so
proudly we hail at the
Twilight last
gleaming who's brought stripes and
bright
stars through the
paress fight or the ramp parts we
watched were so
gallantly
streaming and the rockets
reg the bombs
bursting in air
proed through the
night that our flag was still
there oh say does that star
spangle
B
wave or the
land of the
free and the home of the brave
[Applause]
friend
the house will attend to a request for
Le of
absence Mr Speaker the day illness the
order Mr Speaker the day illness
Representatives Bickford Buras Linda
gold O'Brien pomante Ryan trevan and
Vincent the day important business
Representatives Cole Katherine Kenny and
Susy the day illness in the family
representative
sandborn
these leaves shall be granted unless
house the house will attend to in
introduction of guests Mr Speaker please
welcome Abigail Blanchard student at
gtown high school and Audrey pagee
student from Bedford High School our
day welcome to Welcome to the New
Hampshire
house
[Applause]
Mr Speaker please also welcome Jenna
Scott and Debbie Hardy parents and
grandmother of the singer guests of
Representative MCU Cado Ambler son of
Representative Newell and Leadership
greater Manchester guests of
Representative Wilhelm they are with us
today
the house
welcomes aun Alexander Canada's Deputy
ambassador to the United
States and bernardet Jorden Canada's new
Council General to New England the
members will be attentive while the
council General Jordan addresses the
[Applause]
welcome
[Music]
well thank you Mr Speaker Mari buku and
thank you for the warm warm welcome and
for granting me this opportunity to
address this distinguished body I've
only been in my role as Cil General to
New England for one month today but I've
come to understand that yours is truly a
unique citizens legislature so it's a
great honor for my myself and Deputy
Ambassador Alexander and my team to be
so graciously welcomed by all of you I
also know you've had quite a few
visitors to the Granite State these last
few months as presidential candidates
reached out to voters at your diners
your legion Halls your school
auditoriums so thank you for Lending me
your ears at a time where I'm sure
you're all quite exhausted from speeches
of any
kind now unlike those candidates I'm not
here seeking a vote instead I would simp
simply like to take a moment to reflect
on where we currently find ourselves and
to provide you with some context on the
Canada New Hampshire
relationship it just so happens that 75
years ago the government of Canada
opened its first office in Boston to
represent Canada's interests throughout
New England but of course the strong
connections between Canada and new
englanders date back long before then
our communities starting with our
indigenous people who were the first to
inhabit the land have found reasons to
exchange create innovate and build
together for
centuries the people of New Hampshire
know this better than anyone some of
your families may have been among those
who migrated from Quebec or aadia to
work in the M towns in New Hampshire
over a century ago contributing a
Vibrant frankophone Community and an
affinity for patin that continues to
this day in Berlin lonia NASA and
Manchester and as a side note my home in
Canada is about 20 minutes from lonia in
Nova Scotia and the exchanges between
our communities have only grown from
there there are fun exchanges like when
our hockey teams play volleyball play
here or your volleyball teams cross the
border to participate in tournaments
with their Canadian neighbors or the
Canadian musicians who travel South to
play in your concert halls and
nightclubs like the word Barn in exiter
owned and operated by a Canadian
American
couple there are also helpful exchanges
like when New England firefighters
traveled North last summer to assist us
as we battled wildfires not far from my
home in the Southshore of Nova
Scotia just as Canadian linesmen and
women have been known to come to the
South South when a nor Easter knocks out
your power lines the point is we have
always been there for one another and
I'm here to tell you today you can count
[Applause]
there because we are at a critical
moment for the ca for Canada the US and
the world we're on the edge of a
generational shift as issues like
climate change and artificial
intelligence demonstrate the potential
to profoundly alter the ways we all live
in the after in the aftermath of the
covid-19 pandemic that isolated our
communities and in the face of ongoing
conflicts like those in Ukraine and the
Middle East that continue to stretch our
supply chains we're also seeing a
historic Global geopolitical
realignment in the face of these many
complex challenges we know that the
solutions to these problems will not
emerge from one country they are
challenges that we all must tackle
together for Canada the path to
successfully meeting these challenges
runs straight through the us and for the
US the path to success runs straight
through Canada our two countries share
more than a border we share the same
values democracy rule of law respect for
human rights free markets the balance of
IND individual freedoms and Collective
responsibilities these shared values
have been the basis for our strong
Partnerships and international
cooperation for decades and as we look
to the Future these shared values will
continue to be the bed Rock foundation
of the deep Mutual trust and
collaboration that will guide our two
countries to reach our greatest
potential I'll give you an
example as New Hampshire aims to meet
its decarbonization and energy security
goals your best path to success is
straight through Canada your path to net
zero emissions lies with the people in
Ontario who will make the electric
vehicle batteries that will power those
F-150 lightnings in your driveway or or
to the people in the mine in Quebec who
will Source the critical minerals
necessary to power the battery in that
car globally the race is on to secure
access to critical minerals like lithium
graphite and nickel these critical
minerals are essential building blocks
not only for electric vehicles but for
renewable energy production and storage
like wind turbines off the coast or the
semiconductors found in your iPhone or
the MRI machine in your local
hospital if New Hampshire is to be a
leader in the green IND digital
economies you will need reliable trusted
source of critical minerals You Can
Count On Us Canada has 31 such critical
minerals so there we are here for you
count on us not only because we have the
resources but because we share your
values values of free competition of
strong labor and environmental standards
it's thanks to those shared values that
North America has become an economic
Powerhouse the strength strength of the
Canada US economic relationship simply
cannot be understated we trade over $1
trillion doll in goods and services Al
annually that's over
$250 million every
day as your colleagues on the New
Hampshire Canadian Train Council know
the New Hampshire Canada economic
relationship alone accounts for over $35
billion doar of two-way
trade China may be the United States's
number one largest trading partner but
the fact is Canada is your largest
customer we buy more from the United
States than China France and Japan
combined and New Hampshire companies
have a strong role in that you exported
over $1.3 billion dollar in goods and
services to Canada in
2022 but what is truly remarkable about
our free and balanced trading
relationship at that we not only sell
things to each other
we make things together in fact most
Canadian exports to the US are inputs
that contribute to US manufactured goods
which are then sold around the
world whether it's the Saskatchewan oats
that are manufactured into Cheerios in
Upstate New York or the specialized
piece of Machinery tooled here in New
Hampshire that eventually Finds Its way
into an aircraft built in Montreal or
perhaps it's the auto that crosses the
Border seven or eight times before it's
finally assembled in either aaga or
Michigan or maybe it's the energy that
flows on one of the 70 plus pipelines
and transmission lines that cross our
border every day keeping the lights on
in the factories and the homes in each
and every one of our
communities no matter the sector we
build things together it's that trade
that directly contributes to New
Hampshire's economic prosperity and
competitiveness Canadians and new
hampshirites share the same goal we want
good jobs that will help our communities
keep up with the rising cost of living
and that will pave the way for healthier
more sustainable e economy for the
people of the Granite State and for
Canada good jobs like those by at
Canadian owned businesses like highliner
Foods in Portsmouth which employs over a
100 New Hampshire workers or the various
TD Bank branches around the state that
employ over 200 people from North Conway
down to nashaa in total there are 97
companies Canadian companies employing
over 5,100 New Hampshire
workers and there are even more New
Hampshire companies and workers in every
one of your 10
counties from Coos County in North to
cheser cheser county in the South who
rely on exporting the goods and services
created right here to their reliable
customer just north of here in Canada in
1987 when President Reagan addressed the
Canadian Parliament he described the
border between our two countries as more
of a meeting place than a dividing line
don't get me wrong there is still indeed
a border between us after all we are two
Sovereign Nations but a 5500 miles long
or as we would say in Canada 8,850
kilomet it's the longest and most
peaceful shared border one that I would
Hazard to say is the Envy of the world
our respectful respective law
enforcement agencies are working hand in
hand to ensure our shared border is safe
and protected 247 365 days a year
keeping threats at Bay while making
vital Crossing and crossb trade and
travel as efficient as
possible this co-management of our
shared border is a shining example of a
healthy predictable partnership and with
built-in standards to solve problems
together together we're also committed
Partners in the North American Aerospace
Defense command or NORAD the only
bational military command in the world
just down the road at hansome Air Force
Base in Massachusetts you have the
Canadian Armed Forces serving side by
side with our American counterparts the
same is truly is true at military bases
across the United States our militaries
also serve shoulder-to-shoulder in
theaters around the world whether it's
our naval officers participating in
joint operations to intercept elcid
drugs or our air forces patrolling for
threats in the Arctic or our battalions
in Eastern Europe who are bolstering
security of our NATO Partners our
Collective commitment to peace and
security along with our shared values
have allowed our communities and
countries to
flourish let's not this be let let's not
let this moment be the high watermark
for Canada US
relations Canada and New Hampshire have
a long history together and we have a
bright future ahead of us a a future
built on shared values and goals a
future that every person in this room
will play a vital role in building our
success stories will not be what we do
independently but what we can achieve
together let's continue to walk the path
to a future United because Canada has
always been always been and will remain
your strongest
friend partner and Ally thank you Meri
[Applause]
[Music]
we'd like to uh give you a declaration
I'm not going to read it all in
recognition of the 75th anniversary of
the embassy to of Canada at the United
States of America thank you so
[Applause]
you the house will now attend to the
consent calendar Mr
Speaker for what reason to member rise
Mr speak Mr Speaker I would move that
the remarks of the gentle lady from
Canada be placed in a permanent journal
without objection thank you
sir Mr Speaker from the committee on
fishing game and Marine Resources House
Bill 1228 removed by Representatives
Burnham peternell mcarter Panic Gard
Bailey
are there any other bills to be
removed representative Osburn moves a
consent calendar with the relevant
amendments as printed in the day house
record be adopted are you ready for the
question all those in favor say I as
oppos a the eyes have consent calendar
is adopted under the rules of the house
from the committee on education hb1 1570
FN is referred to the committee on
finance from the committee on resources
Recreation and development HB 1046 FN is
referred to the committee on criminal
justice and Public Safety from the
committee on Transportation H
finance house will now attend to the
regular
calendar
okay
for what reason do as a member
motion I'd like to make a motion to
can't I'd like to make a motion to
102 the motion is in order and having
the motion before us is to reconsider HB
10002 house will be in
order the chair recognizes
representative smart and I would remind
all members that this is about the
reconsideration not about the bill
itself
I thank you Mr Speaker I'd like
to uh vote to reconsider HB
102 um I didn't understand the bill to
begin with and I think quite a few
others misinterpreted it also I'd like
them to have the opportunity to change
the
vote J recognize rep in a
pool
good morning house thank you Mr
Speaker is my understanding that during
the debate on HB
10002 not everyone was clear on what was
going on or the unintended consequences
legislation I am in support of a
reconsideration motion so we can have
the discussion instead of sending it
over to the body behind me
in this house and the proper place to
have that discussion is in this
house I would ask that you guys would
support the motion to reconsider so that
that we can take up either a discussion
of the several floor amendments that are
in your pockets I'm aware of
three or options other options might be
to send it back to committee for further
discussion please support the
reconsideration motion thank you chair
recognize representative mag
leori
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker the
motion we have in front of us is for
reconsideration of House Bill 1002 a
bill that certainly passed this body a
motion to reconsider should state with
some specificity the basis on which the
vote on the bill overlooked some
critical decision points created some
conflict in law or Overlook clear and
obvious facts for instance if we had
passed passed a bill authorizing a
national Safety hotline and discovered
later in the day that the hotline was
taken down or didn't work then I would
suspect we would want to reconsider our
ba our vote based on those facts facts
in this instance on House Bill 2002 we
had a lengthy debate on the facts we do
not have new facts that reshaped the
merits of the bill we did not make an
error that puts the bill in conflict
with law we took a vote the bill passed
reconsideration of a bill where there
were no errors and there's no new
information sets a very bad precedent a
precedent that will be difficult to
justify with our constituents Mr Speaker
I urge my colleagues to press the red
button to reject the motion to
reconsider so that house bill 102 can go
to the body on the other side of the
wall and be judged on its own me merits
again again please press the red button
to oppose the motion thank you chair
Penza thank you Mr chair I urge you all
to reconsider your vote on HB 10002 for
the following reasons for several in
this body circumstances have changed and
new information has come to light since
they cast their vote as we all know is
essential to stay informed and consider
all relevant factors before making a
decision hence we need to provide them
with the opportunity and support this
free
consideration many representatives that
I heard from did not understand the full
scope of the impact and potential
consequences their vote on HB
10002 would have on their communities
but moreover all of New Hampshire whe
whether it aligned with the values and
priorities of the New Hampshire citizens
who hold the contract the contract being
our our constitution by supporting this
reconsideration we are actively
participating in the Democratic process
and fulfilling our duty and
responsibility to make informed
decisions for the greater good of the
granters that being the 1.4 million
people in New Hampshire please press the
green button to support this motion to
reconsider
hb12 and I request for um a division
vote thank you does the member yield a
questions no member does not
Kenny uh thank you Mr Speaker um so I am
standing up today to urge my colleagues
to support the
reconsideration um that is in front of
us uh so look I I know we've heard about
amendments that are here and other
options we should do but if we can get
past reconsideration I do believe that
the committee can do more work on this
bill um and I guess the only thing I
would add is please don't let how you
voted before um make you feel obligated
to vote some way today new information
has come up over the past week we have
learned new things that we should look
into before we make changes to 91a and
um I do think we should have a
discussion before sending it to the
other side of the wall thank you Mr
Speaker
Lyn thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I
I'm I'm not sure to be completely
candidate in the interest of time I'm
not sure that I could say very much more
than my colleague from Hampton so
eloquently said in order to cons to
consider her motion for reconsideration
it seems to me that there really does
need to be something new what have you
heard about what's new I submit to you
respectfully that both in in the
committee where the where you know this
was not a unanimous vote it's not like
this was a unanimous vote in the
committee and then all of a sudden you
know something new came up there this
bill was fully debated in the committee
and there was bipartisan support and
candidly there was bipartisan opposition
I respectfully submit to you that
nothing has changed there is no new
information we made the right decision
this is a perfectly reasonable bill just
as 37 other states have similar kinds of
things I urge you to reject the motion
for reconsideration thank you Mr Speaker
smart as a request a division vote
members take your seats this will be a
division
vote
for
El
the motion before us is a
reconsideration of House Bill
10002 this is a division vote chair
recognizes representative Gilman for a
parliamentary
order thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that hb1000 Z2 passed overwhelmingly
just last week and if I know that we
were debating a policy that a public
body may not shall but already can adopt
would I then press the red button to end
consideration of an established local
control thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is
reconsideration on House Bill 02 this is
a division vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
opposed you'll press the red button
seconds
[Music]
Barry
members have all members pres had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
stay to the
vote 195 voting nay 183 voting nay
reconsideration
passes Rec representative W is
motion Mr Speaker I move that uh house
bill2 be recommitted to the Judiciary
order what reason does a member rise to
make a motion of a higher priority what
is a motion I move to table HB
10002 it is a higher priority motion so
the motion before us is a table House
Bill
10002 representative ly has requested a
e
house will be in order the motion before
us is to table House Bill
10002 chair recognizes representative H
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that this is an important policy but it
is not ready to pass if I further
know that any work that needs to happen
on this bill could happen without with
or without going to the Judiciary
Committee and if I know that a floor
Amendment at a later time could be
brought up to address the unintended
consequences of the bill as passed last
week would I now vote Yes in favor of
tbling thank
you chair recognize representative Lynn
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
um I may be wrong but I thought that I
just heard in debate on the on the
motion to reconsider that there was much
additional information that needed to be
presented if that's true I assume that
most people would agree that the way new
information is usually presented is at a
committee I assume that the prior
speaker wasn't suggesting that we would
bring in Witnesses before the whole
house to testify it if we're going If
there really is more information that
needs to be representative this a this
is a parliamentary inquiry I'm sorry if
I knew that there really was more
information to be presented and that the
traditional and really the only place
that it can practically be presented is
before the committee then would I would
I vote to recommit this to the Judiciary
Speaker I'm sorry red so that so that
another motion can be made I'm sorry the
10002 this is a division vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you're opposed you'll press the red
seconds
[Music]
represent
all members present and an opportunity
vote 126 voting aay 254 voting aay the
motion to table fails now we're back to
the motion of
recommit are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I I those oppose
nay
the eyes have it and the bill is
the majority of the committee on
education to which was referred House
Bill one 1048 act relative to the
commission on Holocaust and genocide
education considered the same report the
same with the following Amendment and
recommendation Bill ought to pass with
Amendment Senator Rick lad for the
majority of the
committee minority of the
committee having considered the same
being unable to agree with a majority
Report with the following resolution
resolve that is inexpedient to
legislate the amendment is
0244 printed in house Record 5 page 30
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the amendment is adopted chair
delure thank you Mr Speaker good morning
colleagues
well now that the amendment has passed I
actually thought I was going to speak
earlier but I can have no objection to
this at this point with the amendment um
so I'll I'll wave off thank
you okay the motion before us is the
majority committee report of autop pass
as amended are you ready for the
question all those in favor
say
the motion before as majority committee
report of autop pass as
amended are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I iose nay the
eyes have it and the majority committee
adopted committee on educ ation to which
was referred House Bill
1166 an act adding an exception from
required Civics competency assessments
consider the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate Senator Mel
Meyer for the
committee chair recognizes
representative
Moffett thank you Mr Speaker I Le speak
very briefly uh in favor of the ilt
motion from from the committee uh
quickly in in the Marine Corps every
Marine is a Rifleman every Marine has to
qualify on the rifle range it's a
universal requirement everybody shares
brings everybody together in fact the
the governor's son is doing that this
week he's graduating from Paris Island
so my point is that uh to have car
voutes or exceptions to take away the
universality of something that puts
everybody together is not a good thing
uh this new Civics test requirement
every single high school graduate now is
to take and pass that we're hearing some
really cool things about every school
doing it uh so to carve out exceptions
uh well intended for whether it's Civil
Air Patrol or Roc is something that uh
many of us oppose and so we support the
itl thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognize representative
Myer
thank you Mr Speaker uh I'm speaking on
a bipartisan vote on this committee to
itl it it's important to note that we a
year ago two years ago actually we
passed this motion to have every senior
take the um the test before they
graduate the committee looked at this
and said well why are we going going to
just take certain students away from
having this having to take this
particular exam and I'm surprised that
uh the representative would speak that
we should have this carve out because he
was the one we the he was the advocate
for that wanted this for everyone to
take it now we're trying to say oh let's
take these folks out there's no question
that the roazzi program and the Civil
Air program is a very valuable program
but it would SE that the Committees
respect for those students who are in
that program that they should still take
the test just as every other graduate
has to take the test so I would urge the
body here uh to respect the will of the
bipartisan vote on this committee thank
you very much Mr
Speaker the motion before us is
1166 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those oppose nay
no
the eyes have it and the committee
adopted majority of the committee on
education to which was referred House
Bill 1206 an act relative to prohibiting
educator indoctrination having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate s of Linda
Tander for the majority of the
committee
minority of the committee having
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority Report with the
recommendation the bill ought to pass
sen valicia leakas for the minority of
the committee the question before us is
the majority committee report of
inexpedient to legislate are you ready
for the question all those in favor say
I I those suppose
adopted
majority of the committee on education
to which was referred House Bill 1553 FN
an act relative to establishing a pilot
program under the Department of
Education to offer spelling to
communicate services to students with
autism
oreia having considered the same report
the same with the following resolution
resolved as inexpedient to legisl
pres of Corine cascaden for the majority
of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with the majority Report with
the recommendation the bill ought to
pass Senator Mike beler for the minority
of the committee chair recogniz the
representative
kofalt thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker I'd like to ask my
colleagues to imagine for a moment what
it might be like if you were never able
to
speak you have the capacity for
language you can understand it you can
hear it you can even think
it but for your entire life you have
never been able to
speak now imagine on top of that that
you have a neurological condition that
inclines you not to make eye contact
with
people people around you see someone who
appears to be staring off into
space they assume that perhaps you're
intelligent this is the Fate that many
people with
Autism and specifically with apraxia
suffer from they are locked in a prison
of non-communication for their entire
lives now imagine that somebody comes to
you and says I know you're smart I know
you're in there
I have found a way to teach people to
communicate people like
you and I'm going to work with you and
we can do this and I've never met
it Gregory Tino a young man who lives in
the Philadelphia area describes that as
began he wrote several years ago people
thought that I had the intellect of a
three-year-old
then I learned to use a letter
board he has since learned to use a
keyboard he Types on a
keyboard his his iPad and his Apple
him Gregory's written four
books he has his own blog the autistic
[Music]
speaks in the hearing on this bill we
had people ask as so in the early stages
of this process do you have to teach
people letters and they said oh no they
already know the
letters in
fact one parent testified that her son
knows Spanish she said we have no idea
how he knows
Spanish but he likes to answer some of
Spanish this bill would create a modest
pilot
program to make spell to communicate
Hampshire The Total Money authorized
under this bill would be
$250,000 over two
years roughly the equivalent of one
full-time person for two years after
three years the bill repeals
itself there were two primary arguments
made against this bill number one this
is facilitated communication the answer
is no it's not there is a methodology
ology called facilitated communication
that was discredited years ago
because the communication was not coming
from the person with autism it was
discredited spelling to communicate
enables free and independent
communication I've seen it myself people
typing on a keyboard no one is sitting
with them no one is helping them they
are fully communicating answering
the second criticism is that there is a
lack of
studies there are a number of studies in
methodology I would argue though that
for
$250,000 we could invest in a
tremendously promising
Innovation Innovation doesn't wait 5 10
15 years for a raft of PE peer-reviewed
studies to come out we have an
opportunity today for a very modest
amount of
money to create a program and expand
autism I'm asking you I'm asking my
chance the much better rebuttal to the
argument that there are no peer-reviewed
studies is the long list of Highly
accomplished people who have discovered
this and whose lives have changed as a
result I mentioned Gregory Tino who has
a Blog and has authored four
books Vincent renella is a political
blogger he aspires to be the first
non-speaking US
senator Jamie
Handley co-wrote co-authored a book
called
underestimated and was the subject of
one of many subjects of the
award-winning film spellers that came
out
earlier uh early last
year Ido Kadar whose book EO in autism
land has has become reading material for
courses on disability
studies Thomas puan disability rights
activist and
blogger Mitchell Robbins another
disability rights activist who describes
this as a human rights
issue Ian nordling who has been named to
the youth advisory Council in hearnen
Virginia and sits on the advisory
iasc haris
sasam who was told over and over again
in his life that he would not amount to
much he certainly wouldn't go to
college today he is a PhD student in
ucal Berkeley's prestigious psychology
program his writing has appeared in time
Newsweek Fortune the Boston Globe
Psychology today the daily Californian
two anthologies and numerous other
Publications Elizabeth
Bonker she has autism and has never been
able to speak she uses an iPad to
type she was named
valedictorian in 2022 of Rollins College
in Florida she has since gone on to
found an organization called
communication for all Elizabeth
describes
this by saying that community ation is a
human right that is the mission of her
organization she also sits on the on the
board of The Advisory Board of the
sasam and that doesn't include the
numerous New Hampshire residents whose
lives have been changed by this what I
hear from
parents is that for the first time my
son or daughter can explain to the
doctor exactly what's wrong with them
it gives them dignity I heard a story of
one young man the first thing he said
when he could spell was mom could you
ask Dad to stop telling me asking me if
I need to go potty I'm 21 years
dignity and it's about independence I
can't tell you how many people I've
heard from who said we have worried all
our lives what's going to happen to our
son or daughter when we're not around
anymore and for the first time ever we
know that he can communicate she can
communicate they won't have that utter
incomplete dependency on us
anymore if this bill passes today it
will go on to the finance
committee this house will have another
opportunity to to hear about the bill
hear objections to the bill and vote on
it
again I'm asking my colleagues today to
give Innovation a chance give people
with autism and araxia a
chance and press the red button so that
an alternate motion can be made thank
you Mr
cascaden thank you Mr Speaker House Bill
1553 is to allow the Department of
Education to purchase a commercial
program to Ser as students who are
identified on the autism spectrum or
diagnosed with
apraxia the program spelling to
communicate is intended for school
students who are enrolled in an
individualized education program and not
necessarily Public
Schools autism spectrum disorder means a
developmental disability significantly
affecting verbal or non-verbal
communication and social interaction
usually evident by age three autistic
children have difficulty understanding
what others are thinking or feeling get
anxious about social situations have
difficulty making friends or prefer to
be on their own they may seem blunt rude
or not interested behavioral approaches
are implemented on changing behaviors by
understanding what happens before and
after that behavior behavioral
approaches have the most evidence for
treatment systems of autism spectrum
disorder they've become widely accepted
among Educators and healthc Care
Professionals and are used in many
schools and treatment clinics a notable
behavioral treatment for people with
autism spectrum disorder is called
applied Behavior Analysis known as
ABA ABA encourages desired behaviors and
discourages undesired beh behaviors to
improve a variety of skills the progress
is tracked and it's
measurable apraxia on the other hand is
a speech disorder of the brain and
nervous system in which a person is
unable to perform task or movements when
asked even though the frequent command
is understood and students are willing
to perform the task the best treatment
known is sign language and or digital
literacy via keyboarding on
computer now comes spelling to
communicate a program that implements a
facilitated
communication the technique of
facilitated communication requires an
adult to hold hold a letter board and
the student must use a pointer to spell
out the words it's reinforced by
physically moving the student hand this
method has been proven ineffective by
multiple scientific
studies the American speech language
hearing Association also known as Asha
does not support this program because it
requires physical guidance and prompting
and it creates dependence on another
person it lacks research and scientific
evidence and focuses on spelling not
speech the association for Science and
autism treatment has conducted many
studies in the 1990s and the 2000s on
facilitated communication programs such
as spelling to
communicate repeated evidence refuted
the use of this program regardless of
the name of any facilitated
communication program that requires
ongoing support from a facilitator the
association opposed and
rejected spelling to communicate should
not be considered as a valid means of
communication after having a discussion
with a board certified behavior analyst
who specializes in services for children
with autism she was clear that quote it
is unfathomable that a New Hampshire
Department would consider this program
as a technique that has no scientific
research to support it and has been
scientifically discredited as a
technique technique now this is not to
say that spelling to commun communicate
didn't work with
some why would we want our public
dollars to be spent on such a program
that has no scientifically based
evidence of positive results and
involves physical contact and
reinforcement this program and house
bill is not in the best interest of our
students I urge my colleagues to support
the bipartisan committee recommendation
to itl House Bill 1553
thank you Mr
Speaker the motion before us is the
majority committee report of inexpedient
to legisl and House Bill 1553 a division
has been requested Senator kofalt has
seats
e
house will be in
order the motion before us is majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 1553 this is a
division vote chair recognize
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if if I know that numerous spelling to
communicate uh
beneficiaries are are are spelling and
communicating independently with
keyboards furthermore if I know that
this bill does not offer grants to any
single vendor or organization if I know
that the national Autism Society has
come out in support of this bill and if
I know that this would make New
Hampshire the first state in the country
to formally introduce spelling to
communicate into our schools and finally
Mr speaker if I know that this bill will
go to finance it will come back to the
house and we will have an opportunity in
the meantime to learn a great deal more
about spelling to communicate would I
then press the red button so that a new
motion can be made thank you Mr Speaker
chair recognize repel B bony for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know as a former special
education teacher that public school
districts already provide a variety of
evidence-based speech and language
services to students with a p and with
autism and aaia based upon their
individual needs and I know that the
American speech language hearing
Association the American Association on
intellectual and developmental
disabilities and other medical
organizations do not support facilitated
communication programs like spell to
communicate because there is no
scientific research to support its
efficacy then would I now press the
green button to agree with the
bipartisan committee recommendation to
itl thank
you the motion before us is a majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 5 1553 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
seconds
[Music]
represent
Gart all members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
vote 102 voting a 78 voting aay
rise to make a motion State your motion
I move that the the debate from the
previous Bill be placed in the permanent
objection
the committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 1561 FN relative to
qualifications for student eligibility
the education Freedom accounts
program Senator McDonald moves ought to
pass the chair recognizes representative
jera
thank you Mr Speaker I rise in
opposition to the OTP motion when the
EFA program was originally instituted it
was supposed to be for the neediest
students and families in our states at a
cost of about
$300,000 now what we see is a program
that is costing taxpayers something into
the ballpark of $24 million a year with
no
accountability we have lifted the
eligibility in income so that graned
state families making six figures can
apply for and be eligible for this
program private schools in this state
are not required to provide some of the
special education services that our
students need we have taxpayer money
going to those schools and yet those
students need to get those Services back
in the districts that are funded by
taxpayer dollar
these private schools are not required
to comply to Title 9 requirements in a
number of cases they are fully free to
discriminate against students based on
the fact that they don't have to comply
to those Title 9 requirements our Public
Schools can't discriminate they don't
discriminate that's the beauty that's
the virtue of our Public Schools that's
why thriving public school systems are
absolutely essential they're absolutely
indispensable to aun functioning
democracy and to the production of
citizens who are capable of
participating in a functioning
democracy Public Schools exist to serve
all of our students not just some of
them our teachers work hard every day to
meet them where they are and in those
cases where they're not able to meet the
needs of those students then appropriate
accommodations are sought we have seen
an expansion of this program we have
heard about its successes we have seen
no evidence to support the claims of
these successes because there is no
accountability because we are not
following up to make sure that that
taxpayer dollar is actually being used
in the ways that we've been told it's
supposed to be used for all of those
reasons Mr Speaker I oppose the OTP
motion and I encourage my colleagues to
you
representative Alexander is recognized
to
speak thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker I
rise today as a proud product of New
Hampshire Public Schools I would say by
and large my education at conquered High
School set me up for success in college
and graduate school and provided me the
foundational education needed to be in
front of you today my story is not about
educational Excellence it's about my
struggle coming to a realization that I
like men I realized I was gay during my
years at conquered high school and I
spent a lot of time reflecting on what
it meant for myself my family and my
community at that time I was not
comfortable telling classmates and
friends about my sexuality I would see
the way other classmates spoke about and
treated those perceived to be gay or had
already come out I wasn't ready to to
speak
up I remember one situation in which I
was standing at the bus stop behind the
school after we were released and a
friend of my friend told me that the way
I was standing was gay and if I wanted
to seem straight I would have to stand
in a different
way that was 10 years ago and in the way
we perceive members of my community have
changed I have also become proud of the
man that I've
become however I'm speaking today in
support of 1561 because I believe
students students like me should have
the choice to attend a school they feel
more comfortable at students who
identify as
lgbtq or like me may not be comfortable
enough admitting it yet should be able
to attend a school that works better for
them and their family and our state
government should support that hb1 1561
is a pro lgbtq bill because it provides
for the ability to use educational
Freedom that may be to attend a school
that may be more welcoming to them
I hope all of my friends who support
lgbtq rights as I do would vote in
you representative tan is recognized to
motion thank you Mr
Speaker HP
1561 is a bill to expand the eligibility
to qualify for the educational Freedom
accounts the EFA program was originally
designed and introduced as a program to
provide economically challenged families
a voucher to choose a private school or
to assist in homeschooling for their
child the one-time household income
requirement originally set in 2022 was
less than or equal to 300% of the
poverty
level just 6 months ago it went up to
350% of poverty
which is about
$109,000 for a family of
four requirements also include that a
child must be between the ages of five
and 20 and will age out of the program
at
22 currently there are a little over
4,000 children receiving the yearly
money from the EFA 75% of those students
did not come from the public school
system but were already going to a
private school or a religious school the
cost for the current year is estimated
at $60
million coming from the educational
trust
fund HP 1561 expands this program that
has little oversight or accountability
either academically or financially by
adding nine new categories of
eligibility in place of the income
requirement a child under 1561 will be
eligible for an EFA if they meet the
following
conditions if they're concerned that
attending a school could lead to the
spread of contagious diseases like
covid-19 the common cold seasonal flu
pneumonia or others they would be
eligible if they feel they are a victim
of persistent bullying which is defined
as three or more
incidents they would qualify if they
test Ted in the 25th percentile and
state standardized testing in any
subject they would qualify if they were
diagnosed with an eating
disorder they would qualify if they were
diagnosed with a mental health
condition they would qualify if the
district guidance counselor determined
that it would be in the best interest of
the child to be in another
school they would qualify if they lived
in a district not NE necessarily going
to school there just living there whose
water drinking water exceeds past
standards they would qualify if they
live in the geographic boundaries of a
school who scores in the bottom 10th
percentile in standardized testing again
they don't have to be going to that
school and lastly if they identify as
lesbian bisexual gay transgender or
non-binary there is nothing in this bill
that indicates Ates how several of these
categories could even be
verified essentially these vague and
wide ranging categories make this a
universal Statewide voucher program for
children 5 to 20 years old and students
in their family regardless of
income let me say this
again while this bill has categories
this bill in reality is a universal
Statewide Voucher Program
if a school district or an area has high
P fast levels in the drinking water
maybe the real answer is not an EFA for
one student but finding out the source
of the contamination and using money to
clean up the situation to have clean
drinking water for all the people and
students in that area let's be real who
has not been concerned about catching a
common cold or the flu or other
contagious dis diseases in a school
private religious or
public children are bullied in school
for a lot of reasons including being
lesbian gay transgender bisexual or
nonbinary this bill is disguised as
helping students who may identify as
lgbtq by allowing parents to use funding
from public education for private or
religious
schools but in reality these schools may
not help but just make things worse
private and religious schools are not
required to follow our New Hampshire
nondiscrimination laws offer services or
help those with mental health issues
special education or eating
disorders these schools are not
compelled to follow the Americans for
Disabilities Act to provide
accommodations Under Disability laws
religious and private schools can and do
exclude lgbtq students or even a child
of an
lgbtq parent from even
applying students who do come out as
LGBT or even questioning at these
schools may be expelled or just told to
leave
immediately we should be focusing on
making sure all our neighborhood public
schools have well-trained staff and
resources to support all students who
may be struggling with mental issues
Eating Disorders bullying sexual
orientation or gender
identity instead of spending money to
pull vulnerable students out of public
schools we should be looking for ways to
make funding more Equitable stop passing
bills that put unreasonable stress on
teachers and students and fully fund
programs that will support students
rather than deflecting our legislative
responsibility
we know that 165,000 students and their
parents choose their neighborhood Public
Schools where children go to school with
their friends and
neighbors where they have professionally
licensed teachers who are dedicated to
Preparing children in learning academics
and meeting the challenges of life in
the
future public money should be spent for
the public good for the cherishing of
public education and as defined in our
state's
Constitution this bill is a fox and
sheep's clothing to try to convince more
people to apply for efas to imply
falsely that leaving the public system
will be better for the vulnerable
students keep them from contagious
diseases past contamination and produce
higher test scores on standardized tests
it doesn't happen without an income
requirement the state will be
subsidizing those already in exclusive
private schools these broad categories
open up an opportunity and will allow
the ultra wealthy in our state who do
not need the state's help to send their
kids to these schools and at the same
time the state doing nothing for our
neighborhood public schools in Berlin
Claremont Franklin and elsewhere
throughout the
state with the addition of these
unverifiable vague category for
eligibility this EFA will rapidly become
an unchecked Universal voucher system
that will be very costly to costly State
obligation and an equally costly burden
for the 165,000 public school students
their parents and local taxpayers I urge
you to vote no so another motion can be
call
Sweeny thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
and my colleagues I stand before you all
today as the proud product of New
Hampshire's public schools in fact
there's no way I'd be standing here and
speaking at this well without the public
schools uh in my town of Salem New
Hampshire that got me here today and and
unlike many uh I had a very different
experience through the public school
system uh that that has really given me
the ability to speak uh when I say that
when I was four years old I could
effectively pronunciate just 27 words I
had to go through three years of
extensive extensive speech therapy
through the Salem School District
through the seed program in order to get
to where I am today I haven't stopped
talking uh since that point where they
got me up to speed with my peers but
that is my background and that's why I'm
so passionate about education because it
is the dis the Difference Maker between
a life where you cannot be heard to a
life in which you can be heard now the
public schools worked for me and I know
the public schools work for countless
others but there are still those that
the public schools do not work for and
that is what this bill is about those
marginalized communities within our
neighborhoods that the public schools
cannot serve properly that is why we are
pushing forward with this bill we've
heard uh conversations about communities
within our state I was pleased to see uh
through text messaging uh the mayor of
Berlin supporting this bill uh and
supporting all of our bills today to
expand educational freedom in our state
by expanding opportunity to these
marginalized communities within the
state of New Hampshire we are expanding
our educational options the choices that
we can provide families and children
that need our help this is still public
money going towards education at the end
of the day we are investing in the
future of the grand State uh and by
passing 1561 which expands coverage to
those marginalized communities that are
are they may not feel safe in their
public school they may not feel that the
school is accommodating to their needs
what they need to do it allows that
family the flexibility regardless of
other circumstances to make the
decisions that best suit them I've heard
a call for a roll call I will second the
call for a roll call on this bill um and
I just plead with you to all vote for
the marginalized communities in the
state vote for the kids that don't fit
in the cookie cutter system and let's
get this job done for the people of New
Hampshire thank
you representative grer has requested a
roll call is that sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call vote members
[Music]
seats
for
where
the motion before
us house will be in
order the motion before us is ought to
pass on House Bill
1561 a roll call vote chair recognize
representative Woodcock for a
parliamentary
inuring thank you Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill allows
eligibility for a $5,000 voucher and I
quote from the Blue Calendar they are
concerned about attending school that
could Le lead to the spread of the
common cold or seasonal flu which by the
way happens when you live in New
Hampshire in the winter I would highly
call these marginalized students and if
I know that public schools lose 5,000
,000 vulture students also lose taxpayer
money which have been used to improve
public school for
$65,000 other students and finally if I
know that many $5,000 voucher students
who may be
lgbtq and who may not get accepted to
these private schools because of that I
would ask now that you vote by pushing
the red button and not and stop this
Universal expans I of this diverse Bill
thank you chair recognize representative
Osborne for parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I wish
to see every child receive an adequate
education but know that a one-size
fits-all system cannot possibly provide
that opportunity for every child if I
know that hb1 1561 will ensure that our
most vulnerable student groups have
access to the wildly popular education
Freedom account program would I now
press the green
button the motion before us is ought to
pass on House Bill 1561 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you'll press the red button voting
seconds
[Music]
representative
Aaron
all members present and an opportunity
vote 185 voting house will be in
19 speak wait AE wait a
minute 197 voting nay the motion aut to
pass
fails chair recogniz representative
itl motion before us now it is
inexpedient to
legislate are you ready for the question
all those in favor say
Speaker for what reason a member
rise Mr Speaker having voted on the
prevailing side I move reconsideration
and urge the body to vote no and I
order representative representative
Barry requests a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
seconded this will be a roll call
so
motion before us is reconsideration on
House Bill
1561 this is a roll call vote you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you're oppos you'll press the red button
for
[Music]
represent all members present had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
vote 189 voting a 192 voting a the
motion
fails committee on education to which
was referred House Bill 1634 FN relative
to Universal eligibility for Education
Freedom account program sen of lus moves
ought to pass the chair recognizes
representative
miler
house the house will be in order the
member has a right to be
heard now thank you Mr
Speaker House Bill 1634 comes to this
chamber without a committee
recommendation it removes a household
income criteria for the eligibility
requirement for the education Freedom
account
program when the EFA program was
introduced in
2021 it was advocated as a poverty
program to assist families under the
300% poverty level it was later amended
to 350% on the poverty level this bill
will would eliminate any family income
eligibility
requirement it would expand the EFA
program to any family with no
limitations whatsoever of their family
income a family income of
$500,000 annually would have the same
status as a family income of
$100,000 there is an indeterminable
physical impact on our state budget
should this become
law now this is problematic since we are
currently operating under a state budget
with no anticipated options on how to
pay for this widely expanded program
proposal
little is known or anticipated on how
the increase on this funding would
impact the availability of state aid to
your public school frankly this bill is
fiscally irresponsible and is an
unfunded
mandate the EFA program is new three
years old the state is currently
conducting an audit of this program
seeking to find its Effectiveness and
fiscal integrity
to expand the program now is premature
until the findings of the state audit
are
analyzed you have to keep in mind that
the EFA program has no
guardrails currently is it a $60 million
program administered through a new
york-based
organization under this bill any student
would qualify for an EFA Grant 87% of
the students who currently take
advantage of the EFA program were
already in private or religious schools
consequently public tax dollars has gone
to support students already attending
independent private and religious
schools only a very few students
currently in public schools left and
took advantage of the EFA
program further there is little
accountability to the effectiveness of
the taxpayer money on the use of EFA
grants we don't know the success of EFA
students we have no test scores Etc the
universally expanding this program makes
the program vulnerable to fraud and
abuse this is what happened in Arizona
when they moved to a universal program a
similar Pro a similar bill was recently
introduced to the conservative Texas
Republican legislature and it was
rejected just as I hope we should do
today remember this bill is contrary to
the stated purpose of the program an
opportunity for lower income families
and students to receive
fisal assistance in their education
outside the public schools this bill
violates the intent of the program and
expands it with no safeguards to its
management and the fiscal
irresponsibility of the taxpayer's money
colleagues I urge you to vote no on the
o2p motion so an alternative itl motion
can can be made on hb1
1634 thank you Mr Speaker chair
leas thank you speaker and thank you
fellow
legislators first oh and I would like to
call first I feel the need to rebut some
of the things that were said
um I was there when this bill was
introduced when the original law was
introduced and it was it was introduced
at with no cap there were States all
over watching because we had no
cap unfortunately some deals were made
in order to get it passed and they did
put a cap on it but the idea that it was
always meant
as a um only for poor kids is is not
accurate at all the original Bill had no
cap it was always intended to be for
every single student in the
state the next is no accountability no
guard
rails you
cannot a parent in this organization
cannot buy a pencil without it being
okayed every single piece of money
everything bought has to be
okay it's not not like some of the
other um programs in other states where
there people are spending money on all
kinds of things everything has to be for
Education everything is okayed
spent
when legislators decide that they're
going to spend money for something to
fund something like education it's very
important that we do it without
discrimination that we do it across the
students one of the things we know and
that we're taught as teachers is that
not all students learn the same in fact
the Nea has an ad that says that every
child you is unique and learns
differently but by saying that kids have
to attend this school by this ZIP
code in effect we're discriminating
against the kids who can't learn in that
code
when I hear people talking
about yes every kid needs to learn yes
every kid has to have an education yes
we want education for all kids and then
they add in the public schools in the
public schools every kid needs to be
funded and given a good education in the
public
schools that is
discriminatory against those kids for
whom it doesn't
work I was sitting in a senate hearing
and a mom sitting next to me began to
vibrate as she's listening to the
testimony of these people saying in the
public
schools and finally she said what are my
kids
garbage she was so upset the idea that
only those kids in the public schools
are valuable only they deserve a good
education and the kids for whom that
doesn't work who cares we don't care we
don't need to fund them we don't need to
make sure they get a good education and
disturbing Universal efas fund the
students not the
system it gives the students the
opportunity to choose a system or
systems which work for them it might be
the neighbor Public School it might be a
charter school it might be a public
school a home school a college some
combination of all of those we should
not be funding systems we should be
funding students please vote red for
does a m yield the questions yes I
do p you may
require thank you Mr
Speaker how does New Hampshire's
education Freedom account program
compared to school choice programs in
other
states our education Freedom accounts
have won multiple Awards including
cluding the award of best
implementation some member you to
further questions yes I always take
inquire we've already heard this
it it's not a voucher program a voucher
program gives a ticket a voucher to a
specific thing this gives money to
whatever that student needs it could be
a wide wide variety of options it's an
account a educational account that gives
the student a a lot of choice and
opportunities which could include public
you the motion before us is on to pass
on House Bill 1634 roll call roll call
has been requested by sentive Miler is
that sufficiently is sufficiently
[Music]
vote
you
the motion before us is a to pass on
House Bill
1634 this is a roll call vote chair
recognizes representative Damon for a
parliamentary
inquiry
thank you Mr Speaker good morning
colleagues if I know that we should not
expand an over budget fledgling program
before the performance audit is
completed and reported and if I know
that our constituents do not want to pay
private school tuition for wealthy
students nor pay for just anything at
all and if I know that New Hampshire
statute prohibits unfunded mandates and
most
importantly if I know that I was elected
to use taxpayer dollars wisely and that
the New Hampshire state budget cannot
afford a universal education grant
program would I now make the fiscally
responsible choice and press the red
made J recogniz Ron of noble for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that our
award-winning efficiently run EFA
program is popular but an income cap is
suppressing
participation if I know that in states
that have a universal program 10% of
students or less participate and studies
show
that public school outcomes improve with
education freedom because of
competition if I know that this will
save taxpayers money because the local
portion of what is spent per student
will stay with the
district and most
importantly if I know that every child
is unique and learns differently and we
should cherish that
would I now press the green button thank
you the motion before us is ought to
pass in House Bill 1634 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you press the red button voting stations
seconds
all members present had an opportunity
vote 188 voting vo yay 186 voting yay
194 voting nay the motion autop pass
fails for what reason do a member rise
Mr Speaker I Rise to move itl on this
bill the motion before us is itl on
House Bill
1634 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say I
iose
nay the eyes have it committee report of
speaker for what reason does a member
rise Mr Speaker having voted on the
prevailing side I move reconsideration
and urge the body to vote
no and I ask for a division vote the
motion before
us who ask for the roll call
Representative Sweeney ask for roll call
is that sufficiently seconded is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
[Music]
vote
clear motion before us is
reconsideration on House Bill
1634 if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you're oppose you'll
press the red button voting stations are
seconds
Ms represent
man
while members president had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
vote 188 voting a 193 voting a motion
for reconsideration
fails L
announ we are doing lunchtime
Roy
thank you members of the veterans
interest caucus we will be all me will
members suspend for a minute all members
please be in your seats for a
minute members of the veterans interest
caucus we'll be meeting for a couple of
minutes uh here in rep's Hall um at the
you
we'll be we'll be at lunch
until
1:00
seats
committee on education to which was
referred House Bill 1665 FN relative to
student eligibility for Education
Freedom accounts program this comes
without recommendation Senator Celli
moves ought to pass the chair recognize
luno thank you Mr
Speaker last spring the income
eligibility for the education Freedom
account program was raised to 350% of
the federal poverty level and that's
right around
$19,000 for a family of
four and with this in place the ETF the
E EFA program now serves approximately
4,200
students but the fact is that most of
these students weren't seeking freedom
from their Public Schools they were
already attending private schools and
this bill increases the income threshold
again and would fund tuition
reimbursement uh would fund a t tuition
reimbursement program for nearly 78% of
the students across our state at a cost
of nearly $45 million a year New
Hampshire taxpayers can't afford
this we're just now starting to be able
to analyze the data from three years of
the EFA program has been around let's
not take on an additional $45 million a
year in new cost until we have a better
handle on how this program is
working it's
unaccountable there's no academic
standards the member want suspend for a
minute it's too loud in here if you have
to have a conversation take it out in
the aning room members have a right to
be
heard thank you Mr Speaker and we just
can't afford it please vote no on the
most motion of ought to pass so that an
alternate motion can be made thank you
Mr Speaker and I request a roll call
cordelli thank you Mr Speaker um let me
start by saying I second the uh call for
a roll call vote uh because I think that
um everyone in New Hampshire needs to
see the people who are standing up for
the best education possible for every
every New Hampshire child that's what
this is about we saw the kids outside
today um I couldn't help but notice the
smiles on their
face Smiles because they were out of
school no Smiles because they have
Choice they're getting the education
that they need and I couldn't help but
think of the quote from an ancient Greek
philosopher who said the mind is not a
vessel to be filled but a fire to be
kindled that's what this is about too
often kids are stuck in a school
assigned to them by their address where
they're getting their minds filled but
no fires are being
kindled we lock kids into artificial
boundaries for the school that they can
attend unless you have the financial
means to
move and I've count countlessly read
about
uh moms who have used different
addresses so that they can send their
kid to a better school and do you
believe that there have been moms
sentenced to jail for lying about the
address so they can get their kid into a
better school how can we let that happen
in this
country the answer is education
freedom but in New Hampshire education
freedom is limited by a family income
cap that has the
change we also heard this morning about
the
myths associated with school choice
programs the myth of
accountability school choice programs
have the best form of accountability
parents can walk if they're not happy
with their kids' education in public
schools what happens if a school is
failing they get more
money we heard about money being taken
from public schools because of the EFA
program name me one school in this state
that has not gotten the money that they
have been promised under our state law
you can't do
it this increase in the Family Inc cap
to
500% uh will increase the cap for a mom
and her her child to about
$91,000 per
2022 guidelines
and isn't it interesting to note that
the family median income for 2022 was
87,500
almost the same as the uh proposed cap
increase uh one more quote for you um
many of you might have heard of Horus
man of Massachusetts who started the
common school which became Public
Schools he once said and I
quote we then who are engaged in the
sacred cause of Education are entitled
to look upon all parents as having given
hostages to our
cause
hostages wrong Horus this is New
Hampshire this is the Live Free or Die
State we don't do hostages to any
school we are going to expand education
Freedom we we are going to support
parents we are going to support all New
Hampshire kids getting the best
education and we are going to light
those Fires for learning in our kids for
green the motion before us is ought to
pass on House Bill
1665 representative cordelli and luno
have requested a roll call is that
sufficiently seconded it is sufficiently
vote
the motion before us is a to pass on
House Bill 1665 this is is a roll call
vote chair recognizes representative
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that HB
1665 would increase the EFA family
income eligibility from
$115,000 to
$150,000 if I know that 1665 expends the
expands the initial intent of the EFA
initiative as a positive program and
finally if I know that the current state
budget is established and it is fiscally
irresponsible to add an additional
funding obligation beyond the current
$60 million devoted to the program if I
know this Mr Speaker would I now vote no
on HB
665 OTP motion and press the red button
so that alternative motion can be made
thank you Mr
Speaker CH recognize representative lad
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you very much Mr
Speaker if I know those who oppose
school choice often claim that efas
siphon tax uh pay payer money from
traditional Public Schools however if I
also know that's rarely true Choice
programs such as efas cost less per
child than the average cost of a per
pupil attending a local public school
your local school if I know that school
choice increases competitive pressure on
public schools and reflects better test
results in States having flexible
learning options such as efas would I
then support expanding the EFA program
by pressing your green button thank you
very much motion before us is autop pass
and House Bill one 665 this is a roll
call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you press the red button voting stations
seconds
[Music]
all members present had the opportunity
to
vote house will attend the state of the
vote
190 house will be in
order 190 voting yay 189 voting nay the
motion
passes and it's on its way to
finance for what reason does a member
finance committee on executive
departments Administration to which was
referred House Bill 1580
FN an act relative to Prohibition of
government procurement of electric
vehicles containing components created
through the use of forc Labor having
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution that is
inexpedient to legislate JC groy for the
committee chair recognizes
representative
ner thank you Mr
Speaker electric vehicles or EVS require
rare earth metals to operate to
understand what this means we must first
understand what rare earth metals are
are they are found in low concentrations
meaning that they're more difficult to
acquire than other metals and even more
difficult to separate from each other
and from the ores in which they occur
that means that the circumstances
surrounding rare earth metals create
difficulty in mining and refining them
this presents real real world problems
related to environmental damage
sustainability and the labor used to
procure such labor intensive products
The Mining and refining of these Metals
is most frequently done at the hands of
forced labor in the worst cases among
children in China and in the Democratic
Republic of the Congo at this time China
has a dominant hold on the market with
60% of Global Production and 85% of
processing
capacity furthermore the Democratic
Republic of the Congo was the world's
largest Cobalt Miner in 2020 with a
production of 95,000 tons nearly 41% of
the world's
Cobalt while these destinations seem so
very far from New Hampshire these issues
are very real and present for us while
our actions to resolve these problems
are limited we can start here at home by
prohibiting the procurement of EVs and
the prohibiting and prohibiting the
government contracts procuring EVS that
may have been made through forced labor
We are following suit with Federal
guidelines and using the power of New
Hampshire's purse to lead with a clear
conscience the policy proposed by House
Bill 1580 is not overly complicated it
would simply require that any Electric
Vehicle Manufacturer provide sworn
certification that consents to personal
jurisdiction by the state over the
manufacturer and certifies that no
entity involved in the production of the
EV or components for sale used Force
labor or child labor through through its
procurement the forces of the free
market will absolutely mold around
legislation such as this and Market
competitors will have no trouble
adhering to a very small and simple
stipulation that could save people and
children at the end of the day there is
no price too high for the prevention of
child or slave labor and the United
States specifically New Hampshire can
and should be a leader in the abolition
of forced labor and child slavery
wherever it exists and that is why I
sponsored this bill and even if I'm the
lone ner I will be voting against the
itl thank you Mr
groy thank you Mr Speaker House Bill
1580 relative to the prohibit the
prohibition of government procurement of
electric vehicles containing components
created to the to the use of forced
labor so we looked at what those
components used produced by forced labor
and I agree with um
my colleague from miramac in that
lithium Cobalt and tungsten are used and
they are produced in the chi in China
the Republic of Congo and South America
however these components are used in
batteries all batteries including
microchips which are used in cars lap
Toops mobile phones flat screen TVs and
any Touch button Appliance so for that
reason because this bill only limited to
electric vehicles we it out the bill and
I hope you will support the committee's
you the motion before us is inexpedient
are you ready for the question division
vote division division has been
seats
motion before us is inexpedient to
legislate on house build 1580 this is a
division vote chair recognizes
representative Harrington for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know what this bill does is simply
say that if the government buys an
electric vehicle the manufacturer of the
vehicle has to certify that no entity
involved in the production of such used
Force labor or oppressive child labor in
its activities last week we passed CRC
CAC r113 which was against slavery in
the state of New Hampshire it's time to
put these words into actions Mr speaker
so if I believe that I will fight I
believe we could fight slavery all over
the world and push the red button and so
you CH recognize representative Carol
Maguire for parliamentary inquiry thank
you Mr Speaker if I know that the Edna
committee has already sent to interim
study a bill regarding government
purchase of electrical vehicles and if I
know that these materials are used in
many components not just electrical
vehicles and we are concerned that the
government purchasing is being
used in the guise of of working against
slavery or Force labor to prohibit
something that is of concern to many
people and if I know that we don't want
to burden our municipalities or our
state with trying to obtain impossible
to get certificates of of clean material
sources would I press the green button
to agree with the unanimous committee
decision motion before us is any
speeding to legisla on House Bill 1580
this is a division vote if you're in
favor you'll press the green button if
you oppose you'll press the red button
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
vote 294 voting a 84 voting a committee
adopted majority of the committee on
fishing game and Marine Resources to
which was referred House Bill
1116 an act relative to certain Firearms
to be used for taking of game considered
the same report the same with the
following Amendment the recommendation
that the bill ought to pass with
Amendment pres of Mike wette for the
majority of the
committee minority of the committee
having considered the same being unable
to agree with a majority Report with the
following
resolution that it be inexpedient to
legislate representative will Darby for
the minority of the committee the
amendment is
0349 H printed in house Record 5 page 31
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I those
oppose nay the eyes have it an amendment
is adopted chair recognizes
representative
Darby thank you Mr thank you Mr Speaker
my name is Will Derby representing the
diverse people of Nashville Ward 8 as an
Ardent Sportsman and thanks to the
lengthy archery season I get to hunt
over 40 days a year predominantly in New
Hampshire and so keeping Land open to
hunting is very important to me
hunting is popular across New Hampshire
including Suburban areas with higher
population densities in the Southern and
Eastern portions of the state hunters in
these areas frequent uh frequent mixed
use areas such as Town Forest and
conservation land which are shared by
bikers dog walkers and
hikers it's common for hunters to use
the same Trails for axis and even hunt
within a couple hundred yards of
people's homes living in New Hampshire
living in Nashville
I frequently hunt similar locations in
pelum Hudson marac Hollis and Brookline
for safety firearm hunting has long been
limited to shotguns and pistols in these
areas from Brookline to summersworth
since these have limited trajectories
compared to classic deer rifles deer
hunting rifles in 2021 this was expanded
to include three large caliber lever
action rifles with Sim similar
characteristics this bill will drama
rically increase the types of rifles
allowed in these shared spaces in two
ways the calibers or the size of bullets
allowed and the action or the method for
loading subsequent rounds this includes
the introduction of semi-automatic
rifles which fire rounds as fast as the
trigger is squeezed taken together this
will allow the use of AR style carbines
for hunting in these communities I am
not opposed to these firearms and have
many close friends who own them they are
legal for hunting in other areas of the
state where there is ample open space in
more dedicated Wildlife Management areas
however these military look Firearms
will raise alarm to the large percentage
of non-hunting public who share these
areas the committee heard testimony
about calls from concerned homeowners
about gunshots near their homes and
occasionally stray bullets even hit
homes during hunting season the presence
of AR style rifles will will further
raise tensions between hunters and
non-hunters and result in more land
closed to hunting by
municipalities Fish and Game opposed
this bill for similar reasons in that
regard this is actually an anti-hunting
bill I urge you to stand with Hunters
seeking to keep public land open to
hunting by voting against the otpa
motion so a better motion can be made
thank you Mr Speaker and I ask for a
division
thank you Mr Speaker I hope everyone can
hear
me this bill is a simple expansion on
the bill that we passed several years
ago that allowed for the use of a lever
action carbine chambered in 357 44
magnum and 45 Long cult in areas that
were designated shotgun and uh handgun
hunting only it's a safety issue we were
able to prove that the ballistics
although they remain the same uh the the
bullet itself was far more accurate when
able to be handled through a uh long gun
such as a lever action
carbine this bill simply expands the
list of the acceptable actions to be any
rifle which means that now you can have
a brake open single shot you could have
a pump action you could have a bolt
action uh although the previous speaker
mentioned an AR I'm not aware of any AR
that's chambered in a straight wall
pistol cartrid if you want to prove me
wrong I i' be happy to listen to that
but uh the end result is that an AR does
not make a p a pistol or a pistol
cartridge more powerful because of the
platform in fact an AR diverts part of
the gases to actually work the mechanism
and it ends up being less powerful
so the the straight walled pistol
cartridge expansion of the calibers that
I can explain to you now was actually
the language that I got from the chief
law enforcement officer Fish and Game
the current law as we passed it has been
so popular that they've had non-stop
calls from Hunters that are looking to
try to use their pistol cartridges in a
long gun so that they have more accuracy
and and less stray bullets and
whatnot in addition fish and game has
determined that this is actually a good
control mechanism for those high density
areas where we've had trouble
controlling the deer population and
there's been a higher incidence of deer
ticks and Lyme disease
so allowing for more methods to be able
to take care of that herd makes sense
and and to allow those Hunters to have
more opportunity to use their guns makes
sense and on top of that a lot of the
people we found that are opting for this
happen to be
females or youth who are just getting
into hunting and who cannot handle a
modern shotgun Which is far more
powerful than any of these rifles we're
talking about the modern
shotgun uh is extremely powerful and the
ballistics are far above anything that
was previously contemplated in what most
rifles do um to be able to handle a gun
that is a rifle but chambered in a
handgun round which is going to be
straight walled so it is less
powerful is a perfect introduction to
hunting for a female or
Youth and it is a perfect way to expand
this in those areas where we need to be
able to control the deer herd so I would
look forward to you helping me support
this legislation that came out
bipartisan from the committee with a
majority of the committee vote green on
OTP thank you very
much representative Greer has a
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently
seconded members take your seats this
vote
the motion before for us is UT to pass
as amended on House Bill
order this will be a roll call vote
chair recognized representative Harvey
Speaker I can't see with these things Mr
Speaker if I know that fish and game
opposes this bill because municip IP
alties should be able to determine the
firearms that are used for hunting in
their
communities and Mr Speaker if I know
that this bill would allow the use of AR
style rifles in town forest and
conservation land in very densely
populated areas of the state and if I
know that it is easy to convert an AR to
a straight walled pistol two examples
are the 10 mimet and 45 ACP
and finally if I know that this bill
could lead to conflicts between hunters
and
non-hunters which would result in more
public land being closed to hunting and
thus this is an anti-hunting bill would
I now press the red button to oppose the
ought to pass as amended motion so that
a better motion can be made thank you Mr
Speaker chair recognizes representative
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that this bill allows for a
more accurate shot and a safer hunt for
hunters of New Hampshire well then I
push the green button to pass this otpa
thank
you the motion before us is ought to
pass the majority committee report of a
pass has amended on House Bill
116 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you oppose you'll press the red
seconds
[Music]
represent
leki all members presid had an
opportunity to vote house will attend to
vote 221 voting a 157 voting nay
adopted chair recognizes a
clerk Mr Speaker pursuant to house rule
47f representative Wier uh waves off the
1665 for what reason does a member rise
to make a motion State your motion
having voting on the prevailing side I
move we reconsider HP
no roll call Mr
Speaker Sweeny has request that a roll
call is that sufficiently seconded is
sufficiently seconded this will be a
vote
for
okay the motion before us is
reconsideration on House Bill 1665 this
is a roll call vote chair recognizes
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker if I know that to
wave the referral to finance of a bill
with an
unknown but very
large fiscal
impact both for our school s and for our
local
taxpayers and if because of that I
definitely want people to have the
opportunity to reconsider their vote so
that they can vote in favor of their
towns their schools and their
taxpayers would I now press the green
button to say yes to
reconsideration
she recognize representative Sweeney for
a parliamentary inquiring thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that the New Hampshire
house just historically passed an
expansion of educational Freedom account
eligibility from 350% to 500% and if I
further know that that bill has been
waved by the house finance committee and
if I know that we can now get that bill
onto the other body and closer to
becoming law in the state of New
Hampshire would I now press the red
button and vote no on reconsideration
thank you the motion before us is
reconsideration on House Bill 1665 this
is a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
oppos you'll press the red button voting
seconds
[Music]
representative while members present had
an opportunity to vote house will attend
186 voting a 192 voting a
reconsideration
fails mes to pass the amendment there's
no debate on the amendment there's a
otpa committee on Health and Human
Service is in elderly Affairs to which
was referred House Bill 1662 FN relative
to restricting simultaneous employment
of certain Department of Health and
Human Services staff with adoption or
child placement agencies this comes
without recommendation representative
kushman moves ought to pass the amend an
off Amendment and offers Amendment
0191 printed in house Record 5 page 35
are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
suppose nay the eyes have it the
amendment is adopted chair recognizes
representative
Weber thank you Mr
Speaker colleagues it's important to
know what this bill
does the bill restricts simultaneous
employment for any employee of
DHHS and forbids them from
simultaneously working for an adoption
agency so why is this a problem it's a
problem on a lot of levels first off
most of the employees at
DHHS have nothing to do with child
placement and therefore we should not be
putting any obstacles in their way of
doing whatever they want to do on the
time that they are not employed by
DHHS so that's number
one number
Services Division of Youth and Family
Services yes
dcyf is the agency specifically charged
with the overseeing of children who are
the victims of abuse and neglect
so here's what happens we had somebody
implying that dcyf employees were
handing off children to adoption
agencies for
money that is an appalling
assertion M susp the member will
suspend state state your point of order
my point of order is that the speaker
that the current Speaker is implying
motive
on the bill by saying that people are
stating what was spoken in our committee
by a person it was just what was stated
in committee
representative point of order is taken
continue so here's what happens when
there is an abuse and neglect
petition first off there is a yearlong
proceeding of about the abuse and
neglect that's happened and during that
year the sole
goal of DCF is reunification of the
family we want to put children and their
families back together and strengthen
their families if we
can at the end of a whole
year if the child cannot be safely
reunified with their family
there is a new proceeding called a
termination of parental rights that the
parents have a right to counsel the
parents have a right to appeal that is a
fully contested new
proceeding and it is not until after
that proceeding has happened the
decision has made and all appeal rights
have been
exhausted that an adoption proceedes
there is no adoption agency involved the
adop the dcyf stays with that child
until they are
safely either adopted by a new family or
placed under guardianship or have
another successful safe
outcome so this bill is a problem in
search of a
[Music]
solution
the
the other concern with the bill was that
it might have forbidden been construed
to to have
forbidden um anybody in DCF to be a
foster parent but you took care of that
with the amendment so that's not a
problem
but the underlying problem that the bill
seeks to address does not exist as far
as we know there are not and never have
been any DCF workers who also work for
adoption agencies and there is no reason
to limit anybody else because there's no
possibility of any conflict of interest
on anybody else in
DHHS so I urge you to vote down the a to
pass so that another motion can be made
and we can get on our way thank you
H thank you Mr
Speaker the prior member mentioned that
there's never been an
issue um and something along the lines
of a a of a solution in search of a
problem that was what was quoted in the
calendar for those who want to read the
bill in its entirely entirety is amended
is on the last page it's a total of two
lines long what this bill does is create
guard rails to make sure that no one
could ever be accused of trying to move
a child from one family to
another having been through the process
once before of of being accused I I have
an intimate
familiarity with some of what happens
within state government not by my choice
but because I loved my
children in this case I also heard a
number of other families who were
suddenly um in the Limelight relative to
DCF and they were concerned that there
might be some mixed motives this would
be an easy way to prevent that
appearance of evil to make sure there
motives let me tell you a story several
years ago I heard I heard of a a great
analogy relative
to to do the right
thing a dad was trying to hire a
chauffeur to take care of his elderly
mom something that's appropriate he had
three applicants he challenged the
applicants to drive up a very difficult
Road I think the Mount Washington
Highway is a good
example and he challenged him to find
out how close they could get to the edge
on the way up and the first guy oh I can
do this no problem I can be within 12
Ines of the edge all the way up the hill
I I'm a very good
driver second one said I can do better
than that I can be within an
eight and the third one said I'm not
going to be anywhere near the edge
that's not good for your
mom that's what we're talking about here
we're talking about making sure there's
policies in place to protect the family
at all costs it's not about how close we
can come to the issue of having a child
mov from one family to another we should
have all the appropriate guard rails to
prevent that from happening thank
you
division a division has been
requested lay on members will take your
vote
e
C the motion before us is a to pass as
amended on House Bill 1662 this is a
division vote chair recognizes
representative Weber for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr
Speaker if I know that children who are
removed from their families
because of abuse and neglect and who are
unable to be reunified with their
families never go to an adoption agency
they are adopted from DCF into their new
families and if I know that the guard
rails that are already in place is the
New Hampshire court system and a series
of at least eight hearings in three
separate judicial proceedings before a
child is adopted would I now press the
red button so another another motion can
be made chair recognize representative
lay on for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that we should be happy that this has
not been a problem in the past but if I
know that it is our job to put in guard
rails to protect children to make sure
that there will be no confusion as to
where a child is placed after being
removed from their family and if I
understand that this is just a common
sense idea that shouldn't need to be law
but does to ensure the safety of our
children would I then vote Yes by
pressing the green
button motion before us as a to passes
amended on House Bill 1662 this is a
division vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you're opposed
you press the red button voting stations
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
vote 18 188 voting a 190 voting a the
motion
fails what reason the member
rise to move in expedient to legislate
for what reason does a member rise to
make a motion of a higher
priority State your motion I move to
table hb1 1662 tabling motion is a
higher motion the motion before us is
1662 are you ready for the question all
those in favor say
I those oppose
nay
okay division will be
clarification
the motion before us is to table House
Bill 1662 this is a division vote if
you're in favor you'll press the green
button if you're opposed you'll press
the red button voting stations are open
seconds
[Music]
e
all members present had an opportunity
vote 188 voting a 190 voting a tabling
motion
fails the motion before us now is
inexpedient to legislate are you are you
ready for the
question a division has been
called roll call has been called by kto
is that sufficiently seconded it is
sufficiently seconded so it be a roll
call
[Music]
vote
the motion before us is inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill
1662 this is a roll call vote if you're
in favor you'll press the green button
if you oppose you press the red button
seconds
[Music]
all members present and an opportunity
vote 190 voting a 187 voting aay the itl
motion
doest
majority committee on Municipal and
County government to which was referred
house bill
1396 act relative to prohibiting
Municipal inspections of owner occupied
units or multi-unit housing considered
the same report the same with the
following resolution resolved as
inexpedient to legislate since David
priest for the majority of the
committee minority of the committee have
considered the same being unable to
agree with the majority report the
recommendation of the bill ought to pass
josal for the minority of the committee
pres of Granger has requested a roll
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
this will be a roll call boote there is
no
debate
doesn't matter put
question
I
pi
I'll
it
[Music]
the
yes
Tim
the house will be in
order where we're at is this is a roll
call
vote on the majority committee report of
inexpedient to legislate the chair
recognizes represent ofala for a pi
thank you Mr
Speaker Mr Speaker uh if I know that HB
1369 or
1396 um is uh the same bill that this
house uh passed last year and if I know
that
the
uh uh the the structure the ownership
structure of uh a man of a building does
not change the the safety aspects of
that building and if I know that if you
rent other
structures uh out to other people you
should not lose your fourth amendment uh
privacy protections uh would I now vote
uh no on this itl motion thank you Mr
Speaker J recognize representative
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that housing codes set minimum
standards for housing conditions that
all rental housing new and existing must
meet to protect the health of his
residents especially in Property
Maintenance and
sanitation and that building codes
protect the public from the health and
safety risk of improperly
constructed buildings or building
improvements without proper inspections
or or code
enforcement and if I know that
HB
1396 would allow the property owner to
make any improvements without any code
and compliance or necessary inspection
and would jeopardize the lives of all of
the housing
occupants would I now press the green
button to itl HB
1396 so that the health and safety of
those res could be protected thank you
the motion before us is the majority
committee report of inexpedient to
legislate on House Bill 1396 this is a
roll call vote if you're in favor you'll
press the green button if you opposer
press the red button voting stations are
seconds
[Music]
represent
Southworth
all members present have an opportunity
to vote also attend to state of the
vote 195 voting a 182 voting a the
adopted committee on resources
Recreation and development to which was
referred House Bill
1045 act relative to requiring a power
boat operator to wear an engine cut off
off switch while operating certain power
bols traveling over Headway speed
consider the same report the same with
the recommendation that the bill ought
to pass s of Ron dun for the committee
are you ready for the question all those
in favor say I those suppose nay the
adopted
committee on resource Recreation
order development to which was referred
House Bill 1049 inact relative to the
prohibition on overnight moing of house
boats considered the same report the
same with the following resolution
resolved that is inexpedient to
legislate representative Susan Vil for
the
committee chair chair recognizes
representative
H chair recognize representative Hil for
a
motion
for what reason a member rise I wish to
make a motion State your motion I move
Griffin thank you Mr
Speaker I Rise to
oppose I Rise to oppose
the motion to indefinitely
postpone HB 1049 is rooted and common
law and and uh it has to do with great
pawns for those of you who don't know
about what a great Pond is under the
concept under that concept all natural
bodies of
water within the state in excess of 10
acres are held in trust by the state for
the
public I don't believe that trust dies
at
Sunset that concept is well rooted in
common law and has always been the rule
in New Hampshire dating back to Colonial
times this bill is about that concept
and restoring the trust that concept
creates almost 250 years ago our fathers
proclaimed that all men are created
equal it has taken all those years of
Civil War and many battles to make that
a
reality even long before the
1776 the concept of the waters are held
in trust by the state for all the people
was enshrined in common law and was
embraced by our Colonial
ancestors HB 1049 will help us live up
Heritage HB 1049 is a bipartisan Bill
resulting from a request by my
constituents some of whom own boats of
approximately 20 ft or so in length
and it also me the
definition contained in RSA 78 27A
section one of a house boat in that they
have sanitary and sleeping
facilities these are weekend
pleasurecraft boats that currently
cannot overnight on the waters held in
trust by the state for the people our
Research indicates that New Hampshire is
the only New England state that has such
a law and may be the only state in the
country that has a section law currently
section two of RSA
270a protects a budding land owners from
the general public beaching their boats
on a Butter's land or tying up on a
Butter's
docks
sorry
here uh section three of the same law is
a general prohibition for the general
public to be a be able to overnight on a
great pond in New Hampshire that section
I I believe is in direct conflict with
the L held concept of the waters being
held in trust by the state for the
people I ask that you uh push the red
button to defeat this motion so we can
you representative Pentel has asked for
seats who requested the roll
call represent representative pretend to
requested a roll call is that
sufficiently
seconded it is sufficiently seconded
vote
e
the motion before
us is in is in definite postponement on
House Bill
1049 this is going to be a roll call
vote chair recognized representative
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that our state is has long held since
colonial times the concept enshrined in
common law that the Waters of a Great
Pond are held in trust for all the
people and if I know that that sacred
trust does not end at dusk and if I know
that
1049 repeals a section of our current
law that is in direct conflict with the
Waters of a Great Pond being held in
trust for the people then would I not
push the red button to defeat this
motion chair recognize pil for a
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that our constituents have spoken loud
and clear in their opposition to
unrestricted moing of house boates would
I now press the green button and vote in
definitely postpone on House Bill
1049 the motion before us in dep
postponement on House Bill 1049 this is
a roll call vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you
oppose you'll press the red button
[Music]
seconds screen push your buttons I press
up
representing
McDonald I'm sorry thumbs up or thumbs
priest okay
sir okay have all members present had an
opportunity to vote I think we've
already attended to the state of the
vote
324 voed y 53 voting nay committee
report the in in indefinite postponement
is
adopted no debate
on hope
so committee on resource Recreation
development to which was referred House
Bill 1429 FNA an act establishing a
procedure for the Department of
Environmental Services to transfer for
ownership of dams to municipalities or
others including making loans considered
the same report the same with the
following Amendment and recommendation
the bill ought to pass with Amendment s
of Dan Wolf for the committee the
amendment is 0227 H printed in house
Record 5 Pages 32 through
33 are you ready for the question on the
amendment all those in favor say I I
those oppose nay the eyes have it and
the amendment is adopted the motion
before us now is ought to pass with
Amendment are you ready for the question
all those favor say I I those P or
no the eyes have it and the committee
report is adopted and it's on its way to
Means the committee on science
technology and enery to which was
referred House Bill 1700 FN an act
prohibiting the intentional release of
polluting admissions including cloud
seeding weather modification excessive
electromagnetic radio frequency and
microwave radiation and making penalties
for violation of such prohibition
consider the same report the same with
the following resolution resolve that is
inexpedient to legislate presentative
Doug Thomas for the committee chair
Bullard
thank you Mr
Speaker members of the
house before you we have House Bill
1700 uh otherwise referred to as the
clean atmosphere preservation act what
this bill essentially does is put
safeguards in place to prevent the
excessive harmful exposure to
electromagnetic radiation as well as
prevent geoengineering in the state of
New
Hampshire now you may be asking yourself
what is
geoengineering well it's a set of
certain measures using specific
technology
to offset the negative impacts of
climate change well that doesn't sound
so bad does
it does it have something to do with
reducing our greenhouse gas emissions no
it doesn't does it have anything to do
with capturing our greenhouse gas
emissions no does it have anything to do
with removing the greenhouse gases that
we currently have in our atmosphere it
does not the methods that I'm referring
to are specifically
designed
to create a global cooling
effect by spraying the atmosphere with
aerosolized particles in order to block
Sun
so I'm not going to speak on what's
currently going on in our atmosphere oh
he's he's talking about chemtrail that's
that's complete conspiracy that's not
going on that's never
happened fine let's let's let's say it
has
I have here in my hands federal
guidelines a federal framework plan to
implement such
measures it's
entitled congressionally mandated
research plan and an initial research
governance framework related to solar
radiation
modification and
specifically in this plan
they talk about the use of stratospheric
aerosol
injections which is pretty much a
classier term for chemtrails but don't
you dare say Chemtrails you got to use
the the correct
term and so I'm going to read a few
document so starting quote this document
focuses on atmospheric based approaches
to solar
radiation modification otherwise known
as
SRM specifically stratospheric aerosol
injection well how is this going to be
implemented from the document quote
instrumented aircraft
platforms airplanes perhaps and aerosol
or aerosol precursor injection systems
would be needed in both s and MCB MCB is
another method Marine Cloud brightening
um it looks to um have have the same um
goals back to the document for sa
experiments of interest is how aerosols
are formed and involved in real
Stratosphere in response to the
injection of aerosols or aerosol
precursor gases for example sulfur
dioxide now according to the CDC sulfur
dioxide is a toxic
chemical it's severely irritating to the
eyes mucous membranes skin respiratory
tract inhalation exposure to very low
concentrations of sulfur dioxide can
aggravate chronic pulmonary diseases
such as asthma and empyema oh that
sounds great well I'm really looking
forward to
that and they also mention a variety of
aerosol materials could be examined so
what other chemicals are they thinking
atmosphere back to the document quote
socioeconomic and ecological outcome
decisions concerning whether and how to
deploy SRM should be based upon an
understanding of the risks and benefits
to human health and well-being of its
implementation relative those
anticipated under the current climate
change traj trajectory so what that
means is look at away your health risks
versus the risks of climate
change right and so hey if if it
produces negative side effects to human
health well you know what it's for the
then it goes on quote Research into the
human dimensions of SRM impacts to date
has been ad hoc and frag fragmented as
needed and kind of pieced here and there
rather than being the product of a
comprehensive strategy as a result
substantial knowledge gaps and
uncertainties exist in many critical
areas research to understanding the
potential nature magnitude and
distribution of SRM impacts on
ecosystems human health and well-being
political and economic systems and other
issues of social concern does not
currently provide a sufficient basis for
supporting informed decisions with
regard to SRM solar radiation
modification implementation so they even
tell you they don't really know what the
potential out uh outcomes are going to
be and the potential uh negative
impacts they to uh they do to a degree
are
assuming is going to be health
risks uh the report goes on to say how
SRM could increase the risk of exposure
to particular ulates accelerate ozone
depletion worsen soil acidity affect
crop yields and negatively impact
ecosystems but hey a after all this is
for you know this is for to lessen the
impacts of climate
change currently New Hampshire has no
protections in place to prevent these
kind of radical
measures and I for one don't want my
children to be exposed to this or your
grandchildren it it sounds to me and you
and you can look at this document
online all right it's it's it's widely
available they want to treat us like Lab
Rats and experiment on us with this
framework
plan
um yes the
bill um it's it's going to be tough to
police these kinds of things
but having a plan in place is better
than having no plan in place so I urge
you please vote against the itl motion
thank
Gart thank you Mr Speaker weapon weather
Weaponry is not a novel technology or
some far-fetched Theory the theory of
and the patents for weather manipulation
go back over 100 years quote weather was
a weapon in Vietnam do you expect them
to discontinue
this quote retired Major General of the
US Air Force Richard H roling I know
that I am not necessarily the most
popular representative in this Hall and
I know that many of you might be
inclined to vote against this bill
simply because I am up here Mr Speaker I
implore the body to put aside their
preconception ctions of me as a person
and open up its mind on this issue for
the sake of our
world Bill Vander Zam the premier of
British Columbia from 1986 to
1991 was skeptical about this as well
but as so many of his constituents were
contacting him about what they were
seeing in the skies he filed the foyer
request with the Canadian federal
government he received a largely
redacted answer but still contained
within those documents were admissions
the government of Canada is aware of
this technology and that they refer to
it as
geoengineering Premier Vader Zam was not
alone Paul helier Canadian defense
minister for four years when asked his
opinion on geoengineering was quoted as
saying quote I think it's one of the
most dangerous diabolical things that's
ever happened to us it's the most
dangerous thing short of a nuclear
cataclysm so I take it very very
seriously and will do everything I can
to try and expose this problem end quote
retired US Air Force Brigadier General
former tactical weather reconnaissance
pilot Charles Jones said quote we need
the answers to get to the bottom of this
national security problem end quote the
these trails in the sky that last for
the entire day and dissipate to become
blanket cloud coverage of our sky are
not condensation Trails condensation
Trails formed by the H2O and the engines
dissipate within
minutes there's not enough water in a
jet engine to create cloud coverage like
what we're seeing Mr Mr Speaker I
unfortunately will likely not be able to
convince my colleagues here to support
overturning the committee's
recommendation on this bill but I do
hope after hearing short bits from the
testimony of decorated servicemen from
the United States and Canada and my
testimony here today that I am able to
get them to start asking questions there
are many PhD level biologists
environmental scientists and other
highlevel experts that have equally as
powerful testimony I urge you to do the
research take the time to look into this
pass a 90c Google Search and understand
that people in power
lie I won't harp on this any further and
i' would like to end with a quote from
our former president Linder ban Lynden
Baines Johnson when speaking at a
graduation ceremony about new the new
technologies of the new age quote it
lays the predicate and the foundation
for a weather satellite that will permit
man to determine the world's Cloud layer
and ultimately to control the weather
and he who controls the weather controls
the world thank you Mr
Harrington thank you Mr Speaker I think
you'll all be happy to know I'm not here
to debate the merits of this bill and
the philosophy behind it but just what's
in the bill itself and why I feel it
simply is not passable or imple
implementable in its form
uh I'll give you a few examples I won't
read them all because it would take too
long it starts out with all one
statement All State climate related
appointees must have administered some
oath we don't know what a State climate
related appointee is it's not defined I
have no idea what they are another
sentence the Department of Environmental
Services shall refer potential
violations as reported by state agencies
of members of the public to the New
Hampshire County Sheriffs and the
Department of Environmental Services Air
Services Resources Division well I would
think the Department of Environmental
Services would know which of their
subgroups to report it to I.E air
resources but why the New Hampshire
County Sheriffs they show up all over
this bill and the county sheriffs have
nothing to do with monitoring air
pollution they don't have the technology
they don't have the Manpower and they
certainly don't have the resources or
the budget to do it yet they're in this
bill multiple times giving
responsibility to do things that they
simply couldn't
do another section it goes on talk about
if some of these things that the
previous speakers were just talking
about uh s cloud seating Etc uh were
detected and a member of the public
produces evidence to the department or
again to the New Hampshire County
Sheriffs that the activity may be
harmful or involves a release of
pollution emissions a ceased and assist
order shall be issued well that's like
saying to a police officer someone told
me a person was doing something harmful
so I arrested him what's harmful it's
not Define
it's not defined here as what is harmful
or involves releasing pollution
emissions I've been involved with
environmental law quite a bit over the
years and normally what's done there is
you say you cannot release any more than
so many parts per million of X Y and Z
you just don't say something is harmful
or may be harmful or involves re release
of polluting emissions anything that
gets release could be classified as a
polluting emission and it goes on like
this another place it says an activity
deem hazardous by the Department of
Environmental Services boy talk about an
open book for a state agency we want
state agencies to be out there saying we
deem something is wrong therefore we're
going to go after you legally of course
not you want to know exactly what it is
you did and what the standard was used
to determine something was wrong and
like I say this bill goes on for pages I
won't it simply is not written well it's
can't be implemented and I urge you to
itl
the motion before us is in expedient to
legislate on House Bill
1700 are you ready for the
requests representative Gard requested a
seconded a division has been requested
e
[Music]
here
order the motion before us is
inexpedient to legislate on House Bill
1700 this is a division vote chair
[Music]
inquiry thank
you Mr Speaker if I know that the
government has framework in place to
spray our
atmosphere you can look into it with
stratospheric aerosol
injections sulfur dioxide base and other
chemicals and if I know this will have
negative
impacts on plant growth our
ecosystem food
production and if I also know that
blocking out the Sun
will negatively reduce the energy that
technology and if I lastly Mr
Speaker if I know that New Hampshire has
no safeguards in place to prevent
anything like this in the state of New
Hampshire would I now press the red
button to vote against the itl so
another motion can be made thank
you chair recognize representative
inquiry the house will be in
order thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker if
I know that during testimony there was
no concrete evidence given uh uh that
referenced the geometric plan that was
ever being implemented in in the state
now if I also know that many of the
dangers presented in this bill uh
referenced
uh lacked concrete definitions and if I
also know that this bill would spend
millions of dollars yet it appropriates
not one penny would I then press the
green button to put this at rest and
vote itl thank you Mr Speaker the motion
before us is any expedient to legislate
on House Bill 1700 this is a division
vote if you're in favor you'll press the
green button if you oppose you press the
red button voting stations are open for
seconds
shapir
that all members had an opportunity to
vote 315 voting aay 58 voting aay
committee report is
is
committee on transportation to which was
referred House Bill
1062 an act relative to the use of
Special cover plates having considered
the same report the same with a
recommendation the bill ought to pass an
and C for the
committee this is going to be a division
vote with par with pis
only members take your seats this will
vote
e
the motion before us is aut to pass on
order chair recognize representative
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
if I know that law enforcement felt this
bill would be very confusing and if I
also know there's no data to support
this request that would benefit our cons
constituents and I further know it's a
pointless Bill brought forward by one
single individual who simply wants to
put their legislative plate on the front
of their vehicle and their really cool
New Hampshire plate on the back of their
vehicle then Mr Speaker when I now press
the red button to vote no so that we can
stop these frivolous laborous and
insignificant bills is out of voter from
taking our
you chair recognize representative Walt
for a parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
this was the simplest bill you gave
Transportation this year and if I also
know that all it does is clarify that
our legislative plates you can either
use one of them or two of them finally
Mr Speaker if I know this bill hurts no
one would I now press the green button
thank you the motion before us is the
autop pass motion anoun Bill 1062 this
is a division vote if you're in favor
you'll press the green button if you're
oppos you'll press the red button voting
seconds
[Music]
repr
represent while members president had an
opportunity to vote household attend to
state of the
vote 198 voting a 177 voting a the
adopted committee on transportation to
which was referred House Bill 1138 FN an
act equalizing the fines for operating
an ohrv with a driver's license
suspended and operating a snowmobile
with a driver's license suspended having
considered the same report the same the
recommendation to Bill ought to pass sen
of Ted Gorski for the committee are you
ready for the question all those in
favor say
iOS n the eyes eyes have it and the
committee report is adopted and it's
going to criminal
justice this is the bill removed from
the consent
calendar
and we're on bills removed from
consent the committee on fishing game
Marine Resources which was referred
House Bill 1228 act relative to
establishing a fishing game guides
committee to determine qualifications
for lure of fishing game guides
considered the same report the same with
the following resolution resolved that
is inexpedient to legislate sentive
Kimberly AAR for the committee chair
Kofa thank you Mr speaker it's been a
long day so I will keep this short you
may wonder why I put my name on removing
this bill from consent when the vote was
17-2 and the short answer is that I
believe that some very legitimate issues
were raised we had a lot of people come
to the committee and testify that they
felt that there were things about the
the fishing game license the fishing
game guide licensing process that need
further review I also know that the the
committee chair has already done some
followup and I deeply appreciate that
having said that I believe that a more
appropriate motion for this bill would
be interim
study therefore I am asking
respectfully that you vote against the
itl so that we may bring a motion of
interim study forward thank you Mr
explain thank you Mr chair thank you
members uh uh the majority of the
committee found that this was not a
valuable uh or necessary Bill uh
although as the previous speaker stated
we did find that there was a lot of
valid areas where we could follow up
fishing game is already doing so one of
the areas where fishing game said that
we needed to uh that that we said that
fishing game was lacking in in their uh
forthrightness in this process was that
there was no sample testing online for
anyone to see what the the oral part of
the exam would would entail we have
gotten an agreement from Fish and Game
and they are currently posting onto
their website uh one of the retied
questions that they no longer use so
that somebody can see a sample question
of what will it will entail and they can
study against
that we also found that there was a lack
of flexibility in the oral part of the
testing for uh those who learn with
different abilities uh everyone was
basically made to go through the same
oral testing process without any
accommodation
however I directed the fish and game
department to work with Frank edbl from
the Department of Education to modify
and pro produce accommodations so that
somebody who learns differently can
still take the guides oral exam and
pass given those areas that were
addressed this bill is no longer
necessary even if it were to pass the
way it's written doesn't solve the
problems that the sponsor wanted to
address in the first place I ask you to
vote green on the itl thank you so much
sen kofalt has requested a division vote
members take your seats this will be a
division
vote
the motion before us is any expedient to
legislate on House Bill 1 228 this is a
division vote chair recognized
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker if I know
that our duties as state representatives
is to be responsive to our constituents
further if I know that multiple um
citizens came in to testify that they
have serious concerns about the process
uh and that an interim study motion may
be more appropriate would I then press
the red button so that a different
motion can be made thankk you chair
recognize representative Carol Brown for
parliamentary
inquiry thank you Mr Speaker uh Mr
Speaker if I know that during the
committee hearings there was no direct
evidence provided that having a guide on
this board has caused the purposeful
failing of an applicant and if I also
know that most boards and commissions do
include a member of the licensed
Community as an expert to assist in in
the assessment of
applicants and if I further know that
fishing
game verbally has promised to update
their website with expired tests so that
applicants can have a chance to study a
test that has been used in the past and
I will say that they have already done
that as of today as I have
Speaker I think think that's probably
where I'm at finally Mr Speaker I would
you the motion before us is inexpedient
to legislate on House Bill 1228 this is
a division vote if you're in favor you
press a green button if your opposer
press a red button voting stations are
seconds
[Music]
all members present had an opportunity
to vote househ will tend to stay to the
vote
312 voting a 61 voting a the committee
adopted chair recognizes the clerk Mr
Speaker pursuant to house rule 47f the
chair of Criminal Justice representative
Roy has waved the second committee
1138 the chair recognizes a member from
Auburn representative wosman for the
third reading
motion
thank you resolve that the house now
adjourned from the early session that
the business of the late session be in
order at the present time that the
reading of bills be by title only and
resolutions by caption only and that all
bills ordered a third reading be read a
third time by this resolution and that
all titles of bills be the same as
adopted and that they be passed at the
present time and when the house adjourns
today it be to meet Thursday February
15th at 1
p.m. the questions on the third reading
motion are ready for the question all
those in favor say I I those n the eyes
adopted
okay chair recognize representative
announcement thank you Mr Speaker fellow
Masons next Thursday will be the third
Thursday where we traditionally would
have our our um Masonic meeting plan for
that please and I will try to get in
touch with you so I can get a commitment
for how many will be coming thank you
chair recognize representative
Barry thank you Mr chairman the house
election law committee will meet at 300
p.m. in room 308 for the purpose of
executive session on House Bill 1370
clerk
okay recognize thank you Mr Speaker just
a a polite reminder please uh as you
leave today if you have not checked your
mailboxes in a while please do discard
the contents if you have not done so uh
also your seat Pockets it is a it is a
good idea to do that as well just a
general reminder uh we do have unanimous
consense so if you are exiting please do
so quietly and at the request of the
speaker I am stating this that yes the
noise is a problem during the sessions
members have not been able to hear
things that they could normally hear we
have added speakers to the rear of the
chamber we have increased the microphone
capacity and the recepted reception
areas within the room but conversations
are leading to your colleagues not being
able to hear so please if you have to
have conversations exit the
chamber chair recogniz representative
consent thank you Mr Speaker Happy
Chinese New Year and happy Lunar New
Year I'm so pleased to be able to share
this day with my black colleagues as we
all celebrate Black History Month
honoring the past addressing the
challenges of of the
present and holding a vision of the
future that unequivocally holds black
Latino and Asian history as American
history and our Humanity as equally
worthy of that
recognition for those who observe Lunar
New Year it's a time to reset at home
eat well and above all be with
family in other words Universal
ideas ideas that I think serve many of
us well whether you celebrate lunar New
Year or
not there are many New Year's traditions
far too many to share them all right
now so I'd just like to finish up by
speaking to everyone in New Hampshire
who will be celebrating the beginning of
the year of the dragon this
Saturday no single legislator can know
all and be all but I like to think that
what we say before the Full House
becomes part of the collective
understanding of our state and our place
in this world so please keep that in
mind during your celebrations G FAO and
we wish you all a Happy Lunar New Year
thank
[Applause]
[Music]
Maguire thank you Mr Speaker members of
the finance committee and others get
regular updates on the state of the
state's
finances and there is good news and bad
news the good news is revenues have been
um moderately higher than expected so we
are in good shape where that goes um
Although our two biggest months of
Revenue are still in the future that's
March and April the bad news is that if
you add up all of the fiscal notes for
all, plus bills in the house and the
Senate it comes to 2. $3
billion so and I'm just as guilty of
this as as others but if you have
sponsored bills that have fiscal notes
and spend
money I I just want to warn you to be
prepared for
disappointment thank you Mr
Speaker for what for what reason member
rise thank you Mr Speaker I move that
the remarks by the representative about
Chinese New Year the Year of the Dragon
be uh placed in the permanent journal
without
objection represent office moves that
the house standing recess for the
purpose of introduction of bills androll
build amendments androll build reports
vacate motions and receiv receiving
messages are you ready for the question
all those in favor say I those oppose
nay the eyes have it and a motion is
adopted the house is in recess until
Thursday February 15th
p.m.